Now we're going to do a quiz and what we're going do is try to calculate how much it cost
to actually get an active customer and let's start with the pay-per-click.
Let's assume we're doing a web company and we spent 75 cents
on Google AdWords for every click that comes to our website here.
Now assume we actually have figured out that it require 4,025 customers
at 75 cents in this campaign.
Next, we just don't want to get them to our website,
we actually want them to sign up for our product.
Assume 3.7% of these 4,025 customers actually converted from acquired customers
to activated customers, so the question for this quiz is calculate what was
the customer acquisition cost per customer.